la pm alors l'avis du comité d'éthique
était très attendu il s'est prononcé ce
matin pour l'ouverture de la pma aux
couples de femmes et aux femmes seules
la question est maintenant de savoir si
cet avis sera repris par le gouvernement
dans son projet de loi
les opposants à une telle extension de
la pma se mobilisent par bio la manif
pour tous la conférence des évêques de
france
mais on écoute d'abord les explication
donnée ce matin par le président du
comité d'éthique le professeur jean
françois delfraissy
il ya de la part de ces femmes une
demande une demande qui tourne autour du
désir d'enfant quelqu'un qui est un
élément qui n'est pas suffisant bien sûr
mais qui est un élément à prendre en
compte et enfin que dans ce monde qui
change autour de la provocation et qui
n'est pas terminé il y aura d'autres
d'autres très grandes questions qui se
poseront autour de la population il faut
un moment donné que le cadre secret et
c'est dans cet esprit-là que nous
confirmons donc notre position
jean louis bourlanges profère des frais
s'ils parlent de demandes de monde qui
change ce sont des arguments qui vous
semblent convaincants pour un problème
absolument absolument fondamental je
crois qu'on peut pas l'aborder de façon
rapide dans le cadre de cette émission
le problème qui est posé c'est ce livre
vous poser comme on doit se situer le
gouvernement je crois que le froid qui a
trois quatre ou trois ans 3,3 à rôle il
ya le conseil le comité d'éthique qui
est clair qu'ils éclairent le problème
le gouvernement qui va faire une
proposition on verra ce qu'elle sera et
la conscience des parlementaires qui
doit disposer
je pense que dans cette affaire il faut
à il faut aborder cette question de
manière totalement opposé à la façon
dont on a abordé le mariage pour tous
c'est à dire il faut pas en faire un
enjeu partisan politique collectif il
c'est une affaire extrêmement pas
seulement ça mais la fin de vie à toutes
les affaires de bioéthique doivent être
examiné à la lumière de la conscience de
chacun nous nous réfléchissons à cela au
modem nous sommes très très loin
d'aboutir à une réflexion collective
pour l'instant et nous pensons que c'est
ce sont les parlementaires qui doivent
la réponse est en marche a dit que les
parlementaires auraient leur liberté de
vote
oui c'est la même chose mais on verra la
proposition je pense qu'il faut prendre
son temps
il faut il faut nourrir ce débat il faut
écouter les gens et il faut prendre
effectivement une décision en conscience
individuellement le débat n'est pas clos
les visuels à non non mais je suis très
curieux avant de vous répondre si vous
me permettez de perturber un peu votre
monde annonce le lancement 6 avant
entendre alexis donc savoir si nous
sommes d'accord ou pas c'est sur moi
mais moi je vais livrer un petit jeu un
petit jeu commencez pas à dire ça y est
effet le prof à roman est un petit jeu
alexis qui a écrit la liberté consiste à
pouvoir faire tout ce qui ne nuit pas à
autrui alors les ihm ce projet sert dit
moi qui sait des classes sont des droits
de l'homme de 1789 par contre de 4
la liberté consiste à pouvoir faire tout
ce qui ne nuit pas aux tristes une assez
belle une définition de la liberté
en quoi est ce que le fait que deux
femmes vivant en couple et un enfant
avec la procréation médicalement
assistée
sany heavy rain aux évêques de france
personnellement ou ça nuirait
ça lui irait groupe s'attend pas de
salut non non non pas du tout ça ne nuit
pas à quoi quand je veux quand je
m'interroge sur le fait d'accorder ou
pas un autre un nouveau droit
je dois me poser de la question de
savoir si ce droit ne nuit pas à autrui
il ya des cas bien ça nuit à autrui dire
ce que c'est par exemple ça lui à autrui
que je roule à 200 kilomètres/heure
parce que je risque de le tuer et donc
on porte atteinte à ma liberté en me
limitant à 130 péricaud j'ai pas dis 80
à 130 sur autoroute et cette altération
de ma liberté et pour ne pas nuire à
autrui
en quoi est-ce que si deux femmes ou une
femme seul a recours à la pma ça nuirait
à autrui ça peut être nuire à l'enfant
qui du coup ils privés du droit d'avoir
un peu et qui pour la première fois dans
l'humanité depuis que le monde existe ne
serait pas le fruit d'un homme et d'une
femme le fruit de deux femmes
mais je dis pas d'être élevé par ses
alors là vient l'argument qu'on a
entendu devient l'argument qu'on l'a
entendu de la diversité actuelle des
structures familiales
c'est à dire pas la famille je parle de
la fin de la filiation de la nature
ontologique de fait qui fait que ce dont
je viens sais pas qui mais lève je peux
être un homme de fable ii c'est pas la
question c'est d'où je viens d'où
viendra l'enfant vous allez lui dire
qu'il a été fait par deux femmes on va
lui dire qu'il a été tué par la porn pas
d'appel à ce père étranger et que ses
parents sont christiane et marie mai qui
donc inapte dans sa filiation dans son
dans son état si il n'y aura pas de
perdre n'a pas l'impression qu'il ya
comme un espèce de mensonges que vous
faites à cet enfant non qui par ailleurs
a dit la vérité n'est pas quand il
voudra connaître son maire maintenant il
y aura le droit il n'est pas question du
mentir et elle ça je suis totalement
contre le fait de leur fille
je veux dire oui m'enfin je peux être
que c'est une nuisance philosophique
au niveau c'est pas quand j'aurai pris
ma phrase si on est obligé de monter au
niveau philosophique très respectable
certes pour qualifier la nuisance
elle est complétée j'en ai fini si vous
prenez le point de vue des évêques six
essais typographie de verifix ici n'est
pas aussi se dit si tu menais volant des
fins dernières semaines on vous dit non
ça les concerne en rien c'est ce que
vous avez dit où je vais aller mieux que
ça assez sympathique
pas du tout petite manifestation du
cléricalisme amanda vente et ricoh
décidément et on va écouter mon seigneur
au petit archevêque de paris qui
s'exprimait sur ce sujet hier c'était
sur rtl et fonctionnaires optique qui
auparavant était médecin pour les femmes
qui auraient un enfant ça c'est
introduire effectivement l'absence de
paternité c'est l'introduire
l'institutionnaliser enfants à droite et
élevé par son père et par sa mère c'est
ce que disent d'ailleurs la déclaration
des droits de l'enfant de l'onu de 91
le problème c'est que si le père est
simplement donneurs de gamètes est bien
le fait même de la parternité disparaît
nous sommes des débatteurs non mais sur
le terrain politique et je me souviens
ni par exemple je me souviens du présent
dans le public le précédent nous jure
ans avec une voix solennelle que nous
n'irions pas à la paix m donc je répond
olivier duhamel est ce qu'il ya une
chance pour eux pris je vous fais le
pari est d'ailleurs c'est déjà en marche
que des gens vont dire la pma ne
concerne que les couples homosexuels
féminins c'est totalement injuste pour
les hommes seront conviendront tout
droit la gpa et nous sommes confrontés
c'est très nous allons aller à la gym
on ira la gestation pour autrui mais non
puisque la phrase de la vidéo mais on
peut l'appliquer à bien des choses et
donc c'est la porte ouverte à beaucoup
béryl donc madame taubira a réussi son
coup quand elle a dit si j'ai obtient le
mariage pour tous j'obtiendrai la gpa
c'est inéluctable
la société a évolué
et les fronts va pas faire marche
arrière les français sont pour on peut
se poser une question éthique est ce que
toutes les évolutions de la science sont
là pour satisfaire les lubies individuel
où les pulsions à l'un des duels où les
besoins individuels sans tenir compte
des besoins d'accueillir le désir
d'enfant une lubie vous y allez fort
petit nom propre et des pressions sur la
gpa la distinction certains disent oui
il ya une différence quand même la
marchandisation du corps et ça ça change
tout de suite et marie parce qu'il
faudra il faudra il faudra évidemment à
maman rémunérer les dons de sperme ce
qu'il n'aura pas assez surtout si on
supprime l'anonymat le style le cas
également volé la vie de l'organisme
suggère dans ce débat c'est qu'on a
moi j'ai pas lu encore la vie je me
fiche un peu d'eux s'ils disent qu'ils
sont pour ou contre ce que je voudrais
savoir c'est comment ils argumentent
comment il analyse car ce qu'on attend
du comité d'éthique c'est paquinou qui
votent à notre place jean louis nadal
aujourd'hui je vais pas lui a
normalement moulin à vent qui très vite
mais les deux un homme et l d'homs et
leur dit il dit que notre désir mois les
éléments partagés alors que le concept
qui n'existe pas les éléments partagés
sont qu' il y as désir d'enfant et que
les situations familiales se sont
grandement transformée en franc bien
qu'en mai ces jeux moi ce qui me paraît
là là où je trouve que alexis soulève un
point qui quitte vraiment tout à fait
intéressant c'est que je crois que le
droit aux origines est quelque chose de
fondamental
en fait nous vivons depuis 50 ans
d'ailleurs depuis mai 68 pratiquement
nous vivons deux logiques
nous vivons une logique sociale selon
lequel alors le jean de la lande le
genre on abolit la nature ont créé des
découpes sur la volonté personnelle
c'est le mariage est une l'essec sont
une création de la société et les
enfants une création de la volonté
et puis parallèlement à ça on a une
remontée impressionnante du génétique
qui se traduit sur plein de choses qui
se traduit par un homme sur la
dénonciation de l'adoption plénière qui
se traduit sur la remise en cause des
enfants souci
et dans un certain nombre de cas moi je
sais quoi je parle dans cette matière on
a besoin qu'on a besoin de trouver ses
origines on a besoin de savoir de qui on
est le fils on a besoin de savoir tout
cela et ça c'est quelque chose c'est
quelque chose qui va qui est un peu
contredit par ses mails donc je pense
que le débat est extrêmement difficile
et là on peut considérer qu'il puis
avouez qu'il peut y avoir une nuisance
ne serait-ce que thérapeutique
enfin combien de combien de malades y
sont traités par la connaissance des
précédents médicaux de votre géniteur
donc la vie hier matin la vie de ce
matin se prononce pour la fin de
l'anonymat du don
melix matin d'accord c'est vrai mais
c'est un élément c'est un élément très
important c'est pour ça que moi je veux
pas me prononcer sur le volet toros
commerciaux mais je pas que ce conflit
est au coeur des pieds et quand on parle
des dons commerciaux faut bien voir ce
que ça veut dire ça existe déjà ça veut
dire que vous y avez demandé on pourra
choisir la couleur le sexe de son
escalade la couleur de son enfant puis
peut-être le qi des parents de quel
milieu social septembre enfin c'est
comme une logique de jénine vers
laquelle on va former le prénom je sais
me coller mais attention alors les avis
des internautes
on les retrouve avec j lr qui nous dire
sur lefigaro.fr opel de pma on pourrait
tout aussi bien se pencher sur
l'adoption pour en simplifier le
processus
johann qui répond à olivier duhamel
précisément sa nuit à l'enfant qui
grandit sans figure paternelle et
monique on peut suivre l'avis du comité
mais en aucun cas la sécurité sociale
doit prendre en charge la pma ça c'était
effectivement une question sous jacente
c'est le remboursement total pas et à la
question twitter quand vous posez le
gouvernement doit-il suivre l'avis du
comité consultatif d'éthique que vous
êtes 60% à nous dire que non
un dernier mot sur ce point peut-être
les accords bc légitime
il ya un grand désaccord ici ce qui
n'est pas le cas dans le sujet précédent
sur l'immigration entre vos internautes
et les français dans leur ensemble dans
les sondages ils sont devenus beaucoup
alors enfin une nuance quand même bon
d'avoir lieu cette grande consultation
dont on parle bizarre aux états généraux
d'états généraux alors seulement ou
quand même c'était ac ou en gros c'était
80% contre la paix mais 90% contre l'aja
bon ça on l'a décidé de mettre de côté
mes plus mais on va dire que c'est les
plus déterminés et motivés par la
question reste en bon on a posé la
récemment avec la sofres on en finisse
de 18 réformes qu'on a soumis aux
français lesquels sont peu importantes
secondaire où ils étaient prioritaires
importance moderne utile la première ces
changements climatiques la deuxième
c'est le réduire le nombre de
parlementaires
la troisième c'est reconduire à la
frontière les déboutés du droit d'asile
on montre quand même l'absurdité de les
hiérarchiser comme intéressant c'est un
sens la 18e sur celle annoncée par la
18e à la 18e sur 18/18 sur 18 s'est
autorisé l'accès à la paix m
non mais là alors ça veut dire je m'en
allais charlier aussi publié des
sandales même vous même vous vous avez
parce que vous êtes honnête quand même
vous avez publié des sondages qui
montraient que c'était un homme et cette
femme mais c'est pour ça qu'il faut
raisonner 60 mais c'est intéressant mais
ça veut dire que si on se met à la place
du gouverneur il faut raisonner en
termes de dynamique et je vous rappelle
qu'au moment du mariage pour tous tout
le monde disait la société prête ça va
bien se passer
il y aura pas de problème et y compris
les hommes politiques de droite qui
d'ailleurs ne voyait pas d'inconvénient
puis là dessus la société s'est exaspéré
et la faire à ta prise là quand on
demande aux gens donc 18e sur 18 et
quand on demande aux gens c'est
prioritaire énonce % qui disent
prioritaires et les gens qui sont contre
qui suit qui disent que c'est inutile
ses 17% donc est aujourd'hui quasiment
deux fois plus de gens très hostile au
nombre de gens très favorable en termes
de dynamique politique c'est intéressant
je veux évidemment que les français sont
plus pour l'augmentation leur pouvoir
d'achat que pour le fait que 1% de la
presse avoir recours à la planète dit
8 sur 18 regard des français favorables
à l'ouverture alors la différence en
tatouage 60 % selon l'insee de 60 à 75
g/t paquet ces deux souches dans
m'écouter droite ça c'est un fait
voilà donc ça va pas dire c'est pas
c'est surtout à la barre c'est une
raison suffisante
évidemment c'est pas un point pour
horizon à 80 % pour bloquer toute
immigration
j'ai pas d'accord on n'est pas au
scalpel sur les ondes mais je voulais
juste souligner que les forces
militantes présentes east qui
s'expriment chez vos internautes qui
n'est pas la même que l'opinion des
français plutôt dans la minorité
on va voir dans quelle minorité ou pas
vous vous situez pour le thème suivant